so Rainicorn is pregnant baby it's gonna
be so much whatever No
yes worry what do all will yes well I
think all the men so okay so this is
lady in people's which we said Jory has
to be another's because we knew everyone
was gonna be other but what's a jewelry
think of people that's why I don't think
that's could last without my opinion
exactly so I'll give it some up real
fast this is a fan and Jake apparently
I've been getting that by the ice Ganga
so it looks for a couple for a few weeks
thought was it that long okay so for
about a few weeks so people's and Lady
Rainicorn they go in to try and save
them after some very heartfelt
conversation yes I think this is the
longest we've heard Lady Rainicorn talk
yeah
and just when you think it's gonna serve
end at the usual amount it keeps going
and it just makes it funny if they know
just just want to stop it just want to
keep it going to make the one to show
lady or a bubblegum reaiiy yeah and
they're all very specific reactions you
know I mean then we're just all and I
mean they were very like you know sort
of in between like kind of heartbroken
but no not holding it together and style
it was like there are very specific
reactions I did that just made it
funnier oh so they go into this weird
sort of vortex they go through what's
pink turd that's big dirty yeah they go
through sweet you know this room full of
eyes all these real little challenges
kind of like a video game I was it got
felt like Cointreau something just all
the weird alien things like coming out
and mouths opening up instead of arms I
don't know helicopter to me more like
Fantastic Voyage well that makes me
contra or Metroid is Mother Brain anyway
so and it turns out it's not the ice
it's these days name again ricardio
ricardio
I always say we're I'm always about to
say Ricardo but like no it's not that
it's for cardio remember a heart cardio
yes and it great to say in fact great to
hear George Takei's voice and he does
officially become unbanned which is just
attaching these arms and feeling like
was that like a paper cup the paper tube
no toys birthday yeah which is great
because the actual you know arms
everything he talks about how he made
out of you know parts of the ice king I
spend you know like whatever weeks or
years whenever putting this together and
then the head is just like a toilet
paper roll nation my favorite was his
bones broken alive
and it still is interested in bubblegum
so but bubblegum using science discovers
that she can you know beat him in a
match because god I couldn't understand
the Jabbar she said I'm just sure was
correct because the size of the budget I
must be correct but she use science to
defeat him and don't some pretty badass
moves really I mean literally it's not
like hey you science in a short hour say
is like no she like beats the shit out
of him like and really aggressively puts
her foot in his face and like squishes
it's pretty funny I don't see she beat
him with science it was just like
there's a knowledge of science no basic
knowledge don't like leave your heart
exposed
well yeah but doesn't she also like I
thought she was saying something else
about like body mass or psychic couldn't
she easily Rick the limbs off and stuff
no she
sorry good she said something about how
she's built it before and she does it
well and he didn't I know how to make a
body out of biomass okay so but she
could I think she could see the no cuz
she looks at the joints that's the first
thing she says she sees the joint I
think she sees their weak well yeah so
okay what but using side you know if I
saw you and then your arm was half
hanging on f9i you saw big arm it
doesn't take science to sit there and go
oh
how would I be moving in its cartoon
science you don't know cartoon science
sir if you put two fingers in a rifle it
will explode backwards that is Marc
Edwards Mythbusters actually did that
and then actually can work with two
fingers one finger they did a single
rifle with one finger
you'll lose your hand for the most part
but yes the gun will I see uh yeah
really yeah banana peel cartoons science
is becoming real
yes oh shit
that's not very fun watch the show okay
okay okay outro so you as a Mythbusters
not ah and then we find out at the very
end that the heartbeats and I was a very
good
foreshadowing there that people saw on
our little harvey mater surrounding
Randall card actually were puppy corns
whatever they're called Oh
Reina pups yes I liked it better all
these yeah and so yeah I thought was
funny it was fun seeing these um these
two characters you know go in together
and serve like in their own way two feet
you know the bad guy serve it like it's
definitely different attitudes which I
like because I like when they go and
they see all the eyes where Finn and
Jake would be like you know uh let's go
or make some surf pondok just look at
all the eyes and go you yeah yeah I like
that like that's funny
um and and they definitely are you know
are fun to watch it wasn't to like I
said especially whatever Rainicorn talks
I don't know why that joke doesn't get
old to me I think they just cut it just
the right moments every time and yeah
and it was nice to see people's actually
do like likes and not just with science
or mouth I mean legitimately like really
ruthlessly beat the shit out of ricardio
and ricardio is still like from the the
day they used them even to now he's both
kind of funny and kind of legitimately
scary the voice again is so funny but
just there's this you're just
uncomfortably so confident
did everything he says they get these
weird close-ups and the way he's drawn
is you know it's like he's got these sir
Apple cheeks they're just and like these
thick I don't know it's little to 3d
yeah it's a light it's like the parts
they choose to emphasize a very strange
parts to emphasize I'm such a very
cartoony looking hard and then to hear
George Takei's voice come out of it just
makes it even stranger it's such a
strange creation so ya know I I found a
lot of fun it was nice to see you guys
came for a little bit too so Jay some
yeah let me go before Jory does a
firebombing begins
cuz this is all going on in real time
and they're gonna hear this to run over
here and beat us all sentences um no I
mean for the most part yeah you hit
everything on the head with how I felt
about the episode the one scene I really
love which I thought you would get a
kick out of his where they first are
going in and well she's talking about
the weapons she has we have science we
can use this in this and the moment
something happened she gets ready she
hits it and it's huge bursts but the
second later just a hand goes push and
she's like oh my field of vision yeah a
little brothers taken and then the bag
is taken and it's like completely
defenseless they can't do any minds oh
no and I love again that's a very you
know it's there's always sort of this
thought that when you have a character
it's just kind of nice just general nice
and there's not too much else to him
it's like cuz I'll be honest why I
started off and start like can we hold
an episode I kind of hope they can good
I serve a civil case is gonna be about
them uh but yeah sorry that weird
technical science jargon tiger even just
putting the hood and stuff I can't see
it's just my field of vision yeah you
know or wasn't me that gun yeah it's
very very funny
yeah and and it worked and they made it
work what just likes to see it's like
you know okay she if both of them can
hold an episode yeah uh I would have to
get up so it's nice and I def what that
was fun um I yeah I thought it was funny
see you guys
point me out to the wolves there are
fenceless yeah watch it with LSP I will
stand by my man honey woman or maybe
both
yeah shall I stand so they can see my
crotch don't look at it stop looking at
his crotch let's say there's an inch of
that no apparently I will the last few
when it was short apparently people were
paying a little too much of my junk I
don't blame you guys really my god it's
not a big screen much of a face cream
I'm planning on doing my crotch in 3d so
I'm giving them what they want
oh sorry I'm sorry Doug for ruining your
oh you may speak no this was I have to
say this was a seesaw episode for me the
title card comes up in her leg what what
the hell are they friends they can't be
friends and then and then I was all like
okay fine I guess
you know people says doing the right
thing and she's doing this and that's
okay and and actually I don't really
have a problem with her but again it
gives me pause when she kicks the shit
out of Ricardian because on the one hand
worse I'm sure if she were a different
character and she was not Princess
Bubblegum I would be sitting here going
hell yeah she kicked back this is
awesome it's so nice to see you know a
girl owning it but it's people so I'm
just like you know this is just another
thing that gets me thinking like this is
a window into who she really I will say
this because there's a one episode where
I forget what happens but like if she
goes really psychotic in that water I
realize
her hair or something nah yeah the Duke
of nuts and it's like it's not like oh
she's just being sir over-the-top crazy
he's like no she's like nuts
and there are always are these little
drops of if she like yeah she seems nice
and really all together but that's just
like wait is she possibly insane you
know like really angry insane and
there's always just these little sleeves
here and there drop even what you were
saying about like that's why I
imprisoned whatever Flame Princess there
and it served like I think they're
purposely always keeping this stuff kind
of a secret cuz it's like yes no or
isn't she had even there it's like yeah
she's fighting back she's kicking ass
but she's like she's not usually that
aggressive like that me and I mean
they're trying of like a lot of lines on
there the eyes I don't really show on
the teeth I mean she's like when she the
way she even grinds her foot into him
it's not enough to just stomp on it yes
I'm trying it's like that's what it says
really quick what I want to find
humorous is I sit there and I say like
how I hate old people I hate tree trunks
and all this stuff and people just kind
of like all I shouldn't say that and
Joey's like I need people's and they're
like I'm kind of a jury on this one in
this episode where it kind of does show
the true side of someone just how
aggressive she is yeah you could chalk
it up to well she probably figured out
that Rainicorn was pregnant but then
again if she knew Rainicorn was pregnant
one could they were going in isn't that
kind of cool right they're having her go
into this yeah or or did she not know
what she was maybe guessing wasn't sure
and when ricardio ties her and throws
her bubblegum kind of flips up and goes
oh god this isn't happening
you know so good we didn't even think it
was that's right I'm the DA didn't think
about
that's what I was thinking about when we
find out she's pregnant it's like holy
crap because he does tie her in that man
what about those little Rena pups
remember remember Bubblegum's reaction
when he he does that she looks mortified
and then throws her and what's her first
reaction runs to her yeah you know so it
could be the whole yeah I'm actually a
frickin nut deep down inside or it could
be I can't believe you did this to my
friend I'm going to effing kill you yeah
you know both but I feel like I just
feel like as all women know I just feel
like you know you do have a little bit
of something in you and and we all try
and hold our shit together but sometimes
it comes out you know and not in a bad
way baby probably you know someone
that's fairly innocent will obviously
get very angry and still fights but they
wouldn't exactly know how to fight as
well as someone saying it properly but
no no I honestly go what you were saying
there when I saw her beat the shit out
of ricardio there I'm thinking like wait
a minute like she you know the last time
they encountered he was about this tall
had tiny little arms and everything and
he tied her up somehow and in this one
he's got these massive arms you know and
and he's ready you know he bested Finn
and Jake and Ice King and stuff like
that and she's like thinking as I was
ripping them off LaVon awesome
so I'm thinking more sort of like what
you said that or both of you said that
maybe was suddenly the realization that
maybe rancor was pregnant and then when
you saw that happen it's like something
snapped and that just gives like the
ultimate energy to go because I think
anything you know can just like hit that
trigger and you know and get some of
going and discover strength they never
knew they had because I mothers lifting
cars in LA exactly you know and I think
with her in the past like she's gotten
like psychotically angry before but she
never like beat someone up or anything
this is the first I feel like
legitimately did something and was until
you brought them not thing I'm like yeah
she didn't really do that until then
for that she was free she was hurt she
was composed oh my field of vision but
even in the beginning if you think about
it my first moment where I was like oh
because I do that every time I see her
on screen to know is that she's just
here's lady like freaking out in Korean
you know min is missing and and peoples
is just like no they've been missing for
you know I don't know however many weeks
but I know it was weeks and she's just
sipping her tea like well now I know
they're here she's just in no rush
whatsoever she's just well-known oh
she's calculating it though to be fair
she's getting I think that's very
scientific that very deductive you can't
just blindly rush in yeah no hold on I
want to see a few things really rushing
it I want to see this the initial
ricardio appearance you never you may
want to think about it maybe she was
blindsided she was talking turned around
knocked her up like a million times - as
are you saying it could be of something
as simple as that nuts really has been
this is captured a couple tiny in in the
early sea in the early season long he
had to save her a couple times and then
isn't around to save her anymore because
he's not in love now she has to save
herself now she has to kick ass was I
was saving herself in saving that's what
I'm saying look asked herself is because
you're right she hasn't been no I just
want to say this save I know some woman
girl who's pretty tiny and at some point
in her life you know wasn't very
aggressive or anything and it also was
like oh man I'm gonna become defensive
and start beating people up no basically
jory tiny little Jory
in high school learned to defend herself
she learned to defend herself
and got past that I'm quiet I'm nice on
the nice shy little person and needed to
defend herself and finally kicked s kind
of like people's
yes I'm comparing you to people's is it
are you just coming to God do you and a
psychotic episode and that's no I know
that's what I'm saying
she doesn't scream as love I'm trying to
speak some foreign language a night
brother it's under braces but I'm yeah
he's not racist every time you speak yes
yar I won't feel like a pirate but I was
trying to be racist past races towards
pirates yeah I'm trying good how do be
racist towards ninjas ah